update again uh on uh those mortar
rounds being fired from Lebanon into to
Israel lebanon's armed group Hezbollah
says it was behind the rocket and
artillery attack on Northern Israel
let's get more now from our
correspondent Ali hasham he joins us
back on set Ali so Hezbollah now
actually coming out and saying look we
were behind uh this rocket attack
what does this mean Ali there's a
statement clear statement saying that
okay part of this attack is in the path
of liberating what they said liberating
the remaining parts of lianes occupied
land and in solidarity with the
Palestinian resistance and preserving
and struggling Palestinian people so
there is a there's a kind of a context
here they're putting aside from the
Lebanese uh point which is uh normal in
their rhetoric they're saying that they
are trying to show solidarity with the
Palestinians now this is a clear warning
sign heah is sending warning signed to
the Israelis through shells on Israeli
posts in occupied Li territories from
hb's point of view and saying if this is
going to continue we are ready to get
into this war and widen the uh uh space
or the the the area of operations so so
so so just for the time being ali uh
this Remains Not uh a a broadening of
the battle space but more a contained
Skirmish with a message well and an
attempt to contain but with the history
between hasah and Israel and the big
operation yesterday the the the large
scale operation yesterday this doesn't
seem good because this is in a way or
another going to escalate the whole
situation it's going to take this
situation into a new and different level
into new and different angle and that's
why everyone right now is keeping their
eye on on what's going to happen and
actually from yesterday everyone was
asking withb take this step now it seems
that hasb Allah already planned this
step and is going forward step by step
towards kind of stating that they are
ready to get into this battle and
yesterday Muhammad D the the the
commander General commander of of Kasam
brigades of Hamas called on the Lebanese
resistance the pales the yemeni the
Iraqis and the syrians to get into this
into this battle and to unify the
banners and the fronts um Ali so again
for our intern viewers just talk us
through uh the significance of this
border area historically well this is uh
this area has been occupied since 1967
after the 16 1967 war and there are uh
different claims over this land whether
it's Syrian land Lebanese land or part
of uh the Israeli lands so uh the
Lebanese has been uh uh calling on
Israel to withdraw from the shs for
years this start I mean this issue of sh
land U occupied territories was raised
after Israel withdrew from Lebanon in
the year 2000 and then we saw several
attacks including uh in 200 uh but like
just like yesterday the 7th of October
2000 Hezbollah launched an attack there
and took several Israeli soldiers as
captives around 23 years ago and that
didn't steer War but that took hisbah
and Israel towards a prisoner swap few
years later now this is just happening
once again because every time there were
account settling between hisbah and
Israel hisbah will go to this area
because it's part of the Mandate
hasballah believes has from the Lebanese
government and from the Lebanese people
according to hasb Allah's rhetoric to
liberate occupied territories hasah
didn't go to a different area that's
disputed within Lebanon because Lebanon
is a polarized Society is a polarized
country is a country with serious
political crisis so Hezbollah wants to
show that he's going on the path of
legitimacy and not uh kind of against
the government's policies all right Ali
thank you very much a very complicated
situation thank you very much indeed for
unpicking that for us all right let's go
back to Zena Hoda she joins us uh live
uh from the Lebanese capital uh Beirut
Zena good to see you so uh that breaking
news uh that lebanon's Hezbollah saying
it's behind uh this mortar attack this
is pretty significant isn't
it well no doubt yesterday morning Hamas
called on armed groups in Lebanon
Hezbollah included to join the fighting
in Israel hezbollah's response was one
of posturing in its initial statement it
said that it was assessing the situation
there were threats in that statement to
the Israeli government telling them that
understand what has happened um and
today we have military activity across
the Israel Lebanon border so hasbalah
heeding that call in its statement
saying that it is doing this in
solidarity with the Palestinian and what
it said was the Palestinian resistance
uh but Hezbollah was also very careful
in choosing the type of weapons it used
and the target mortars instead of long
range missiles the Shah Farms which is
disputed territory claimed by Lebanon
and not Northern Israeli settlements yes
it targeted an Israeli radar position in
the past we've seen flareups along the
border more often than not uh shelling
would Target open spaces it was more
like uh you know messages even when
Israel responded and shelled the sources
of fire they would Target open spaces
both sides really treading very
carefully not to lead to All Out War
this time a step further if you like
hitting an Israeli radar station so hasb
is saying that we are ready to join the
fight we are here but still like you
have been saying this is still
relatively contained uh and Zena we we
were talking earlier weren't we I mean
Palestinian armed groups have been
calling for uh Hezbollah to join the
fight but not everyone wants to get V do
they no has Allah has many enemies in
Lebanon political parties who believe
that this is a group that implements uh
Iran's agenda in the country Hezbollah
does not shy away from the fact that it
is backed by Iran it gets its funds from
Iran so many Lebanese believe that they
should not be implementing Iran's policy
and focusing on resolving the country's
crisis the country is facing multiple
crisis a political crisis there's no
president there's no functioning
government at a time when the state is
nearly bankrupt uh people lost their
savings billions of dollars in Banks uh
have been are trapped in Banks uh
unemployment is high people are trying
to leave the country this is a country
which also hosts a million Syrian
refugees there's a lot of social
tensions uh so the country really has a
host of problems and cannot deal with
another one so Hezbollah has to be very
careful in its actions and that is why
one of the reasons why it chose to
Target the Shabah farms in one way or
another to tell the Lebanese well this
is quote unquote a legitimate fight
because Shabbat is occupied Lebanese
territory but even that um this is just
going to deepen The Divide in in this
country all right Zena h a live for us
there from the Lebanese Capital Beirut
Zena thank you